I recently spoke at a conference titled
Christian Revival, Our Post-Liberal
Hope, co-hosted by Pusey House, Oxford,
and the Danube Institute. The full
15-minute presentation is linked in the
description.
I said what I always say, that many, if
not most, Western Christians have
abandoned a morality. Like atheists,
they fixate on the material world,
leaving a vacuum that Islam exploits.
The solution? Stop behaving like
doormats. Stand up for what's right,
boldly and unapologetically, as the
champions of Christendom once did. Now,
at one point during my panel's Q&A, a
woman asked a question. Here it is, plus
my response. Uh
without wanting to sound too um
controversial, um are we not being
terribly arrogant thinking that somehow
we, rather than God, can change the mood
in this country? The one thing I haven't
heard someone say is all the movements
of the spirits have come from the edges.
Wesleyan, you know, when we have
famously had revival. It's actually
about listening to God and asking him
how we should move, rather than us
having all these theories about how
what's going to happen next. Um I don't
know how that looks like in the Anglican
Communion, but I would suggest that all
of us in the Communion of saints
uh would be doing well to really listen
to God's call. And actually, if we did,
that might happen again, that revival. I
sympathize very much with what you say,
but, you know, I'm reminded of the old
adage, God helps those who help
themselves. And so, on the one hand,
it's also very vague and it sounds pious
and it's very appealing, and I'm not
against it, but it also that kind of
thinking can lead to a lot of social
paralysis, which I think has been going
on actually for quite many decades. So,
I I think it's a symbiotic relationship,
as it always is with God. Okay, you
know, maybe you of course God starts and
initiates, but you have to work with
him. So, I'm I'm for listening to God,
but I also don't think that should not
become a sort of uh
uh call to just being inactive and uh
you know, paralyzed and just waiting for
God to take care of everything. In fact,
I think that's the idea that to a
certain degree has led us to where we
are.
Now, here's the thing. While I agree in
principle with a bunch of what she said,
it seems to me that there's already too
much trying to listen to God and too
little acting, precisely because the
former concept has paralyzed the latter.
The fact is, acting decisively is not
arrogance. It's actually obedience.
Or look at it this way.
What does waiting on or listening to God
even mean today?
How do you distinguish his voice from
your own endless inner chatter?
It becomes subjective mysticism.
Happily for me, a simple man, I need no
such discernment. God has already given
me his word, plain and clear. And
scripture commands bold action, not
pious inaction.
Consider the following verses from the
Old Testament. "The Lord will send a
blessing on your barns and on everything
you put your hand to," says Deuteronomy.
God blesses effort.
"Whatever your hand finds to do, do it
with all your might," Ecclesiastes.
Proverbs says that the diligent rule,
the slothful are enslaved.
There are many more such verses that
honor the active, not passive, man and
woman.
The New Testament is even more adamant.
Paul declares that if anyone is not
willing to work, let him not eat.
No waiting for divine memos on provision
here.
Worse, if anyone does not provide for
his relatives, Paul says, "and
especially for his immediate family, he
has denied the faith and is worse than
an unbeliever." Failing to act on behalf
of your people and family makes you a
hell-bound infidel. So says Paul, the
real Paul.
"Work out your own salvation with fear
and trembling." continues the saint.
"For it is God who works in you both to
will and to work for his good pleasure."
We act, God works through our action.
Partnership, not paralysis.
"We are created in Christ Jesus for good
works which God prepared beforehand that
we should walk in them." Paul writes to
the Ephesians.
The path is ready, to walk it boldly is
obedience, not arrogance.
One can go on and on. Faith, as James so
memorably declares, without works is
dead.
Jesus himself condemns passivity in the
parable of the talents.
The two servants who take initiative and
earn their master a profit are told,
"Well done, good and faithful servant."
The one who buries his talents out of
fear, waiting for explicit orders from
the master, is called wicked and lazy
and cast into outer darkness where there
will be weeping and gnashing of teeth.
Christ, the real Christ, labels such
inactive caution wickedness, deserving
of hell.
Trying to listen to God can be genuine
piety. I'm not arguing that, but it can
also be a perfect excuse to justify what
at heart is not piety, but rather
cowardice, sloth, complacency,
irresponsibility, and fatalism.
Do nothing and feel holy because you're
waiting on God.
That mindset has already gutted the West
and paralyzed Christians from resisting
evil.
Words of piety that paralyze one from
acting and allow evil to triumph are not
from God.
Christians must act in humility, yes,
never arrogance, but act nonetheless.
God has commanded that Christians expose
the works of darkness, that they seek
justice and correct oppression.
And he has armed Christians with two
swords, one against spiritual evil, yes,
but another against tangible, physical
evil as well. By all means, pray and
seek humility.
But then obey the word already given
you. Stop waiting around for a miracle.
Okay, if you'd like more details on this
particular topic, see my original and
much more comprehensive article on
Substack, where I hope you'll go and
subscribe. Link in the description.
Bring back
the fire.
the flame.
Bring back
the fire
and the
righteous name.